I need to stop helping people get famous
they are having a hard time or get
publicity because getting in a fight
with me is a really good way to get on
the front lines Megan McCain isn't
backing down the 34 year old co-host of
the view has landed in the headlines a
lot recently for getting into fights on
the talk show so when she stopped by
watch what happens live with Andy Cohen
on Tuesday she didn't shy away from
talking about her two recent on-air
battles with Anna Navarro and Pamela
Anderson me maybe I was clumsy in the
way that I Abby was I don't I don't know
what you just said but I said don't
scream at me I'm two feet away things
got so heated with Anna Megan actually
walked off the set I just want to say
the walking off footage we are told by
producers to leave the table if it's too
heated and I get touched up backstage
with my makeup so that's what I was
doing and I've done that like many times
over the years then there was this
awkward moment between Megan and Pamela
he was allegedly kicked out of the
Ecuadorian Embassy because he was
defecating everywhere and creating no
that's not true there was video up
things that happened I mean I don't
would you do if you're locked in a room
for just really quick Sears well I
wouldn't be a cyber-terrorist which he
is that's the two of them going at it
over the 52 year old actresses
friendship with WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange I will say I was a big fan of
hers growing up I actually gave her
final Playboy as a gift to my husband to
get a crush on her growing up and I was
really disappointed with how it went oh
and if you thought she stopped there you
thought wrong Joy Behar actually gave me
some really amazing advice that I need
to stop helping people get famous they
are having a hard time or get publicity
because getting in a fight with me is a
really good way to get on the front
lines but I stand by everything I said I
think the method she's giving is
incredibly dangerous within two terms to
Julian Assange and cyber terrorism but
Megan doesn't just have beef with Pamela
Oh calm down sir she even called out the
views studio audience I will say the
audience is extremely combative and it's
nice to be in a positive audience okay
and the sort of like
the booing and the heckling is a lot
every day and I'm paid your death of you
I'm paid to give a different view yes
and so I would like us all when people
come to roll it back
et recently caught up with Megan and she
explained why she's not afraid to get
heated on the show I think that's why
people like the show is they know it's
not scripted and they know it's not
we're not being phony and I'm not trying
to placate to my audience I always say
we're like the only show that'll talk
about like JLo and a-rod and North Korea
in the same show and I think that's
important
[Music]